uh you have a lot of tattoos yeah I do
can we explain a few of the more notable
ones that you would feel like you know
because you got you got a lot and
they're very like
there's some other father there looks to
be a church there
is that a hookah or is that a genie lamp
no it's actually an old perfume okay
it's a perfume bottle yeah but I like
that people are like a jellyfish a
jellyfish is my favorite animal this is
there's a type of jellyfish I think it's
called The Eternal jellyfish why do you
uh love them so much because it's the
only animal I mean they're just cool
like they don't have brains and they're
living like they're literally just like
floating around but they're alive and
like they're not really conscious like
it's I just saw one for the first time
yeah but this eternal jellyfish lit it
can live forever it's the only animal
that lives forever oh [__] so once it's
like it I think it's something like if
if
um
if it gets like
feels a threat or something happening it
just starts at the life cycle all the
way over and goes back to being a polyp
and then we'll start that's wild every
isn't that crazy have you ever been to
Rocky Point no I was in Rocky Point last
summer and I was surrounded by jellyfish
and I cried like a [__]
I was afraid I was like my [__] well
I'm gonna have to get pissed on did you
get stuck I didn't I was afraid I was
like someone's crying like a [__] they
were everywhere
I just all of a sudden I looked around
and I was like is that a plastic oh [__]
it's a [__] it's like seven jellyfish
I wasn't actually crying but I really
was like I'm done
I started panicking I know that feeling
now I was in Australia one time I was
like some dude's gonna have to pee on me
like I don't even know the guy no no no
no okay no yeah I'm okay you never know
shout out to R Kelly but I'll pass you
can't knock it to you hard pass hard
pass on the stranger P
um okay so what else do we have here
what is the fruit on your shoulder is
that a fruit this thing right here right
here
this yeah oh this is um uh saboro Dali
he has a not a fruit oh Bali it's an egg
actually so he has a uh he actually has
a Art Museum in St Petersburg Florida
where I used to live really the Bali
museum is there that's dope yeah yeah so
it's an egg with a flower coming out of
it yeah you got some Vibes what is well
who's Nancy that's my grandma shout out
to Grandma yeah gotta pay homage to
grams do you like to play craps is that
why you have dice no I have dice because
I've been rolling a dice since 97 it's a
fixed time I like that are you were you
born in 97
wow when were you born 87
yeah I got a decade I remember 97. do
you do you really for sure what's what
is like the most vivid memory you have
from 97 walking around Christown Mall
without my parents
do you have any parents what happened
because I was a bad kid who would like
my all my friends are older so I'd be
like 10 years old running around on the
red line in Phoenix [__] going to
Metro Center in the Christown Mall
watching my friends steal stuff oh my
God yeah Valley Metro good place yeah
yeah uh so for you uh it's been a long
time since you put out music
pre-pandemic even yeah what's been going
on
um I've just honestly
oh god I've been writing okay the whole
time album's ready to come out now I
think there's just been a lot of uh
obstacles okay that have come up that
I've had to kind of maneuver around to
make it to this point so I'm just I've
just been trying to like personal stuff
business stuff both and a lot of times
they are both yeah they can be both I'm
an artist so like my work is me so
everything I take everything really
personally which is also that kind of
bad I need to work on like separating it
a little bit more right but um but yeah
everything is like super personal to me
so pretty much everything that has to do
with work is like so the album is called
grudges correct yeah why grudges
I hold a grudge very easily it's hard
for me to if you're from the south side
I get it yeah it's really it's really
hard for me to just be like okay because
also like loyalty is everything to me so
like if I'm and I'm I really try to be
like the best friend that I can to
people I'm just like a good person so if
I'm being
what I think is an amazing friend to you
and you think I'm gonna be an amazing
friend to you and you're like
just [__] living in it and then you
do something to [__] me over it just
shows me what kind of person you are
because I don't I don't change like
coming into no situation I'm always
gonna be myself I'm always going to be
open have you probably dealt with a lot
of that being in LA because the music
industry is full of weirdos which is so
shitty to say because I feel like a lot
of times it's like I wanted to say like
oh it just gets a bad rap or like
there's no I really like that it's
probably a little worse the truth it is
the truth most people who are like your
Associates or friends here are only that
as long as they see the benefits coming
down the pipeline or it's like trust me
I know yeah it's crazy 100 everybody's
kind of offer themselves but I have met
a few a few a few real ones a few ruins
for sure that's for sure a few grounded
people is your 18 year old best friend
from Phoenix who you moved out here with
still around she's not here but she's
gonna move back oh what's she doing
she actually moved
to South Mountain too which she didn't
live there so she moved to South Phoenix
she moved to South Phoenix voluntarily
yeah yeah well her mom lives there so
she like went oh she's coming back but
she likes it because like she hikes
every day and you know it's different
she's hot
it's really hot yeah